-Our next guests kick off
their North American tour
on October 2nd.
Performing "Beguiled,"
please welcome
the Smashing Pumpkins!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ So swallow hard the serpent ♪
♪ Of many tags and faces
hid in masks ♪
♪ Coiled 'round this lung
until the last ♪
♪♪
♪ He'll crack your boots,
young pagans ♪
♪ 'Cause like you, I was
hatched to traipse on cold ♪
♪ And seventeen's a long drawn
way from hope ♪
♪♪
♪ And I've learned these
lessons I was taught ♪
♪ Taut, so taught ♪
♪ And now I'm telling you ♪
♪ Return the faith ♪
♪ They're smashing out
the veils ♪
♪ Return the faith ♪
♪♪
♪ And there's no escape ♪
♪ So return the faith ♪
♪ With charging light brigades ♪
♪ Return the faith ♪
♪ You've gotta move ♪
♪♪
♪ So as betrayed by rainbows ♪
♪ Here I convey, I've sold out
your dear cause ♪
♪ And the king has
placed us in his jaws ♪
♪♪
♪ It's sure no place
can hold us ♪
♪ So in this scene,
I'm December ♪
♪ And you're June's wretch ♪
♪ And my ideals
lay gasping as in death ♪
♪♪
♪ And I've learned these lessons
I was taught ♪
♪ Taut, so taught ♪
♪ And now I'm telling you ♪
♪ Return the faith ♪
♪ They're smashing out
the veils ♪
♪ Return the faith ♪
♪ And there's no escape ♪
♪ So return the faith ♪
♪ With charging light brigades ♪
♪ Return the faith ♪
♪ You've gotta move ♪
♪♪
♪ Return the faith ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]